[Music]
on this Friday night two violent arrests
involving police in Canada this is not
an isolated incident
the shocking RCMP video of a First
Nations chief tackled to the ground in
Alberta and what police in Manitoba say
about this also tonight the history
lesson Britain's colonial past as
anti-racism protests raged plus the
government's plan to make temperature
testing mandatory for travelers at
Canadian Airport and ending blood
donation discrimination it makes me feel
like I'm a little value the ban on those
who want to give under scrutiny
global national with Donna freezin Robin
Gill good evening and thank you for
joining us
after weeks of growing demands for
actions some disturbing new video is
raising questions about police tactics
here in Canada
Winnipeg police released this footage
today showing an officer kicking a
suspect during an arrest we'll have more
on that in a moment
but we begin with the investigation into
the violent arrest of a First Nations
chief in northern Alberta it was
captured on video by an RCMP dashcam a
warning what you're about to see is
disturbing that is Athabasca Chippewa a
First Nation chief Allen Adham being
tackled to the ground and punched in the
head during an arrest in Fort McMurray
in March Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
says he watched the video and called it
shocking like many people I have serious
questions about what happened the
independent investigation must be
transparent and be carried out so that
we get answers globals David akin walks
us through what we know about what
happened the night of the arrest 2:00
a.m. outside the casino in Fort McMurray
an RCMP cruisers dashcam switches on to
record an officer investigating an
expired license plate sticker the truck
belongs to Allen Adham
the chief of the Athabascan Chippewa and
First Nation he was a passenger and his
wife Frida was driving the incident
quickly escalated we have all now seen
the shocking video of chief Adams arrest
and we must get to the bottom of this
like many people I have serious
questions about what happened what
happened was an attempt by the officer
to arrest Adams wife Adam intervened the
officer then tried to arrest Adam
almost immediately a second officer
jumped tackled Adam and while on top of
him delivered a blow to the head Adam
who was charged with assaulting a police
officer and resisting arrest
he spent the night in jail and emerged
the next morning looking like this the
12 minute dashcam video is now evidence
that Adams legal team put before in
Alberta Court
day two have the charges thrown out the
RCMP says the actions of the officers
were quote reasonable Adams lawyer
disagrees this is one of the clearest
cases of unnecessary police brutality
Public Safety Minister Bill Blair who is
a former Toronto police chief says in a
statement the release of dashcam footage
depicts a disturbing level of force we
also know that this is not an isolated
incident
far too many black Canadians and
indigenous people do not feel safe
around police it's unacceptable and it's
government's we have to change that in
the meantime that dashcam video is at
the heart of an investigation by
Alberta's civilian police review agency
and that agency put out the call today
for anyone else who might have video of
the scene in front of that casino and
those investigators will determine if
there's been any police wrongdoing Robin
David akin in Ottawa thanks David
throughout history the relationship
between First Nations and the RCMP has
been a difficult one fraught with trauma
and mistrust heather York's West reports
on how this new video has struck a nerve
in Alberta's indigenous community the
images of this dashcam video are
difficult to watch for anyone but among
members of Alberta's indigenous
communities the emotions are raw to see
that happening you know things
automatically brings anger to our know
our people I was horrified I was angry
and then I was well not surprised I mean
I've seen I think we've seen videos like
this before and I've actually witnessed
things like that in in my own personal
life but to fully understand these
emotions and this trauma you have to go
back and understand historically the
role of Canada's RCMP has not always
been one of protection in our language
we called in a geek one that means
people that capture the whole purpose of
the RCMP was to subdue indigenous people
subdue First Nations and ensure that
they stayed on reserve
even in this era of reconciliation
numbers paint a troubling picture
according to the correctional
investigator of Canada indigenous people
make up 5% of the general Canadian
population but they account for more
than 30% of the federal inmate
population the Deputy Commissioner of
Alberta's RCMP this week denied systemic
racism continued to exist within the
organization but on Friday he said he
was wrong
systemic racism does exist in the RCMP
my statement earlier this week
was not intended to minimize the
experiences some people have endured in
working with or interacting with the
systems and policies of the RCMP you
know policing is just one thing
Lindstrom says indigenous people have
learned to navigate a society stacked
against them from the courts to schools
and even healthcare systemic racism runs
deep and it will likely take much more
than a single video to lead to any real
change heather York's West Global News
Calgary the Commissioner of the RCMP is
trying to clear up comments she made
earlier this week about systemic racism
in a statement Brenda lucky said I did
not say definitively that systemic
racism exists in the RCMP I should have
as many have said I do know that
systemic racism is part of every
institution the RCMP included throughout
our history and today we have not always
treated racialized and indigenous people
fairly
today Winnipeg police addressed another
video that surfaced online showing an
officer kicking a suspect during an
arrest yesterday the grainy footage
posted to social media shows officers
pinning the suspect to the ground one of
the officers needs him in the shoulder a
few seconds later another walks up and
kicks him twice police admit it's a
tough video to watch and explain the
circumstances today with the police's
own video the department says the 33
year old was high on meth had vandalized
a building and was threatening people
with what appeared to be a handgun
investigators say they discovered a
knife on him during the arrest
that kick likely saved his life if that
individual gets ahold of that knife
that's in his waistband
an officer see that and he has that
knife in his hand you're potentially in
a lethal force encounter the suspect is
facing multiple charges including
possession of a weapon resisting a
police officer and assaulting a police
officer most people know the name George
Floyd the black American who died in
police custody last month there is
another name a Canadian family wants you
to know
DeAndre Campbell two months before
Floyd's death he was killed by a police
bullet and as far NASA reports he's the
one who called police for help his
family describes him as fun-loving but
quiet he didn't go out much he liked
staying home drinking coffee and
listening to music but on April 6
DeAndre needed help he had schizophrenia
and called 9-1-1 officers arrived he was
tasered shot and killed his family can't
understand why there shouldn't be
sending police with guns for a mental
issue they should be sent in proper
trained people with an ambulance Ontario
is a Special Investigations Unit is
looking into what happened whatever the
outcome of that investigation the
shooting is another in a long list of
police interactions disproportionately
affecting people of color I understand
completely why they would feel that way
the police chief in Peel Region where
DeAndre lived acknowledges that systemic
racism is a problem we'd be foolish to
think there's no racial bias and any
Police Agency but the chief says it goes
beyond the police department
we're not mental health professionals
and like we're not youth professionals
we're not addictions professionals and
yet the onus to change must come from
police I kept calling forcefully for
this real system have changed that we
need to bring about in policing that's
from the former head of the Winnipeg
Police Service the first black police
chief in Canada yep said for too long
police and has operated a little bit
like an island unto itself telling the
community this is how we are going to
pull
the community an urgent change deandre
Campbell's family says can't come soon
enough
I just wanna dude what do we look like
when they see us cuz I this way we don't
feel like human beans peels police chief
has asked Ontario's police watchdog to
expedite the investigation part of it
will surround a knife that was found at
the scene investigators have spoken to
DeAndre Campbell's family but they have
not spoken to the officer at the center
of this case and the reason is because
he hasn't agreed to an interview or
provided his notes and according to the
police act it is his legal right to do
that
robbing for a Candles story in the
relationship between black people and
police are topics you're covering
tonight in a global special tell us
about that well Robyn first we found
very little data surrounding police use
of force and the black community we did
find one Ontario Human Rights Commission
report from 2018 that found in the City
of Toronto if you are black you are 20
times more likely to be fatally shot by
a police officer then if you are white
now Ontario's Special Investigations
Unit has just said it will start
collecting race-based evidence following
its BC counterpart but critics say it's
not just about the data it's about
changing policing and police tactics
we're gonna have more on that in
tonight's show and we are also going to
go back in time as we've heard leaders
over the past couple weeks say the
systemic racism doesn't exist in Canada
we're going to explore Canada's history
of anti black racism and slavery that is
often ignored
Robin Farah no sir in Toronto thanks
Farah and our Global News special living
in color being black in Canada airs
tonight at 7:00 the use of controversial
no-knock warrants has been banned in
Louisville Kentucky crowds of
demonstrators cheered following the
unanimous decision to approve Brianna's
law three months ago Brianna Taylor was
shot and killed in her apartment after
police executed a so-called no-knock
warrant the wards allow officers to
enter a home
without permission and without
identifying themselves the police were
looking into a narcotics case and the
targets were actually operating in
another neighborhood no drugs were found
in the apartment Taylor a first
responder were shot eight times in the
confusion there's growing concern the
u.s. may be in the early stages of
another flare-up of Kovan 19 more than a
dozen states are seeing an increase in
cases that's prompting some areas to put
their reopening plans on hold but as
Jennifer Johnson explains others are
pushing ahead in at least 14 US states
there are record surges of kovat 19
among them South Carolina Florida and
Oregon reporting their highest numbers
of new cases since the pandemic began
two weeks after the Memorial Day holiday
weekend Oregon putting the state's
reopening plans on hold for at least a
week the virus tape makes the timelines
we don't make the timelines with new
cases up over 90% in Arizona health
officials worried they'll run out of
intensive care beds we're seeing
increasing numbers and we're starting to
see some strain on our hospitals with
the u.s. surpassing 2 million cases
Arkansas is also seeing the virus spread
but not delaying its next reopening
phase regardless of what we see in the
next week we made the right decision in
Texas hospitalizations have risen four
days in a row some health officials fear
America's death toll could hit 200,000
by fall I had hoped the the fact that
people are spending more time outside
that it's summer we would not see such a
big increase so fast
US President Donald Trump who has pushed
States to reopen will soon hit the
campaign trail but now requiring rally
goers to sign a waiver not holding him
responsible if they contract the virus
adding to the concerns millions
shoulder-to-shoulder protesting the
death of George Floyd many at the
rallies were these 20 and 30 year olds
they're going to go home and they're
gonna bring it to the people in their
household experts predicting another
wave of Kovach cases in the next two
weeks setting up the potential for a
deadlier summer than expected Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington if you're
planning on catching a flight this
summer be prepared to have your
temperature checked today the Prime
Minister announced passengers
traveling by plane to from or within
Canada will be tested anyone with a
fever will not be allowed to board the
new measures will be phased in starting
at the end of this month temperature
checks only screened for one covin 19
symptom but the government says this is
an extra layer of safety the federal
government is extending its military
operation inside Ontario and Quebec
long-term care homes by two weeks until
June 26 Quebec's premier had asked the
military to extend its deployment in
hard-hit care homes until mid-september
the government says it's planning to
replace soldiers with trained members of
the Canadian Red Cross policy under
scrutiny
coming up the push to end blood donation
discrimination
it's national blood donor week but a
portion of Canadians who want to give
aren't allowed Canadian Blood Services
rules forced men who have sex with men
to wait three months before they can
donate it's a policy the Prime Minister
calls discriminatory and promised to end
it five years ago as Abigail Beeman
reports the matter is now in court
Christopher Karras tried to donate blood
instead he ended up in court it makes me
feel like I'm of little value when he
learned he was banned from donating as a
gay man Karras launched a case with the
Canadian Human Rights Commission
even though ending the ban was a 2015
liberal campaign promise the government
is now fighting Karras in federal court
I was really surprised and shocked we
will work to end this discrimination
Friday Trudeau said more changes are
coming soon NDP MP Randall garrison has
been pushing to end it for six years he
launched another motion this week there
simply is no science to show that there
is a risk to the blood supply from
eliminating these discriminatory
restrictions when you look at the risk
factors associated with new new
diagnosis of HIV in Canada it is still
related according to Health Canada in
2018 there were twenty five hundred and
twenty-nine newly diagnosed HIV cases
41.4% of them involved men who had sex
with other men Canadian Blood Services
says managing donors and supply is a
complicated balance safety concerns are
rooted in Canada's tainted blood scandal
when thousands of people contracted HIV
and hepatitis C in the 1980s where we're
wanting to go in due course if the
research suggests that it's possible is
to a different kind of screening
questionnaire entirely that's the idea
of a behaviour based screening questions
for everybody about what kind of
behaviors they engaged in Canadian Blood
Services tests all donations for
diseases including HIV the concerns
around
what's known as the window period after
infection but before the virus is
detectable dr. Dustin Costas COO says
he'd support a short deferral period
that applies to everyone asking people
to defer their haters for a week prior
to donation or afterwards you know many
people would make that sacrifice
costas q says when there's a call out
for blood donations like at the
beginning of the Colvin 19 pandemic it
feels like a slap in the face in the
LGBT community Global News asked the
Prime Minister if he plans to drop the
case against Christopher Karras but he
didn't answer
Abigail Beeman global news Ottawa mined
the past
still ahead Britain's colonial history
under a new lens
around the world the death of George
Floyd has spurred calls to remove
historical monuments with ties to
colonialism and slavery from North
America to Europe statues have been
vandalized or removed and in the UK the
events have triggered a new awareness of
the country's colonial past Redman
Shannon reports to many he is the
greatest Briton of them all today
Winston Churchill's likeness is hidden
away in anticipation of more black lives
matter protests last Sunday a protester
vandalized the statue calling Churchill
a racist the wartime leader did believe
in racial hierarchy but remains a
national hero slave-trader Edward
Colston is a hero to almost no one but
the way his statue was removed angered
mani - for many people of color here
this is about more than just political
correctness they say it's about
acknowledging that the legacy of
colonialism hasn't gone away
we said many of the issues that
happening right now related to you know
the transatlantic slave trade so a lot
of people don't like because making
Richard Benjamin is the head of
Liverpool's international slavery Museum
an institution that aims to fill what it
believes are important gaps in Britain's
history curriculums this is about
education the philosophy of the school
in one generation will be the philosophy
of the government in the next juliet
jokes Romero has written a play about
the end of British slavery my master
what string me up it explains how a
staggering fortune was paid to slave
owners in the 1830s as compensation for
losing their property in other words
their slaves a debt only paid off by
Britain five years ago how is it that
the British public did not know that
every person every working person was
paying their taxes towards the bailouts
of slave owners abolition was delayed
partly by this man
Henry Dundas the powerful politician who
gave he
named to one of Toronto's main streets
his likeness also sits high above
Edinburgh for years sir Jeff Palmer has
campaigned for a new plaque that fully
explains Dundas his actions we may now
go for the future where the politicians
might say knock down a statue
we'd rather you knock it down and we
were not gonna put a deuce on this past
week edinburgh council said a new plaque
will finally be placed at the foot of
the monument just as the statue of
another slave trader Robert Milligan was
removed in London different solutions
for a difficult history that often gets
ignored Redmon Shannon Global News
London
us-a up next the American petition with
a mission correspondence from Trevor
Noah's The Daily Show have a unique
proposal for Canada they want us to
invade America it's all in the name of
comedy but their passionate plea has
garnered a lot of attention it's time
for someone to invade the United States
specifically Canada that's right we're
asking the good people of Canada to
invade us the correspondents jokingly
lament America as a country in crisis
ravaged by disease where the economy has
collapsed and soldiers patrol the
streets in a tweet they say they're
calling on Canada to invade the United
States and restore democracy and they're
asking people to sign an online petition
so far it's garnered more than 50,000
signatures and the hash tag invaders
Canada is trending on Twitter hilarious
and that is global national for this
Friday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is the Rideau Canal in Ottawa
thank you for watching and I'll see you
tomorrow and Sunday goodnight
[Music]
you